welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss we just got a new trailer for
mortal kombat coming to hbo max
it is a red band trailer and we're going
to do new rockstar's first
reaction to a red band trailer and the
fact that it's red bands good news to me
because i want this to be violent as
this is a game i grew up playing on
second genesis with my older brother
a game i was probably too young to play
but when you're the youngest of five
your parents don't give up
what you do i also just had a great big
brother uh so let's react to this
uh point out some stuff maybe that you
might have missed and go into some
theories for what this madness is going
to be here we
go first learned about this seven years
ago
on a mission in brazil to capture a
wanted fugitive
we got there it tore through our unit in
seconds
the target has superhuman abilities so
they're kind of redoing jax's origin
okay
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions at dragon market
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
as mortal combat
fate of earth is in our hands what
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill
what
okay
get over here
oh man what okay let's talk about this
this is just
pure bloody fan service and that's all
we really want from this right
i don't care what this plot is it's a
fighting tournament to save earth realm
i don't care i just want to see them
fight what do you think darla that was
pretty wild right
this is what mortal kombat is they fight
they rip each other's skulls out and
then they lick the blades
i'm a good big brother this is too
violent for you you gotta go she's a
[ __ ] i got dog hair on me now but
before we continue thank you to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero
sugars and zero artificial flavors each
16 ounce can contains
300 milligrams of caffeine super
creatine
coq10 and bcaas i am sipping on
rainbow unicorn not like those
thundercloud unicorns the unicorns that
make you feel happy when you sip them
it's just sweet and light like you're on
the back of a unicorn
leaping over a more depressed unicorn i
honestly rely on bangs when i'm shooting
those early morning after shows and i
don't want my eyes to look like i'm half
asleep
when i'm trying to break down these
easter eggs i need my mind to be alert
check out bang on instagram you can get
10 off your order at dangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars 10.
rainbow there you can buy a variety pack
of bang energy or grab a 12 pack of
citrus twist
bankster berry the new delish strawberry
kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 and receive
10
off your bang energy order that's code
new rockstars 10 for
10 off so yeah we got all the returning
favorites we got sub-zero scorpion
goro liu kang gung lao sonia blade uh i
remember seeing right at the end there
that looked like reptile right
yeah definitely kano fighting reptile
there glad he got in there
we got a shout out blood ice dagger a
move i didn't know i wanted or
needed okay so the one missing from this
though is johnny cage
we don't have a thousand dollar pair of
sunglasses to break that's a bummer
but he was kind of you know our movie
star our protagonist our way into the
90s movie
i don't know if i need him here it'd be
great if we could have a cameo or
maybe he like dies early on i guess some
theories about this newcomer cole young
right some people are saying that he
might be johnny cage
i don't think so he seems to have some
kind of like you know
birthmark or a dragon mark that links
him to this whole clan war between
the clan of sub-zero and the clan of
scorpion hanzo but this
sub-zero is behind that in the lord
spoiler winning bihan kind of dies off
it is later replaced by koi lang
that could actually be cole young's
character here he could kind of become
the new sub-zero that'd be pretty sick
like he's the one they're hunting down
and later by the end of the movie he
kind of takes on that mantle the
get over here is a nice kind of batman
roar there
but it feels guttural it feels intense
he's angry it's not just a catchphrase
he
wants him over there at that moment i do
love how we end with this
finish him montage and that's how the
trailer finishes and
one by one they go down it's sick it's
brutal it's bloody
i do love the new redesign of jax's arms
you know they rather than just feeling
like
silver coating over his arms they're
like new
techno cybernetic arms they can see
through all the mechanisms and chunks of
it i love that they feature liu kang's
finishing move
invoking that whole fire dragon they
seem to know what fans want from the
mortal kombat games and the
past movies that had kind of a goofy
campy feel from the 90s but
obviously have a place in our hearts
let's be honest folks most of us
aren't really going to care that much
about this act one backstory that lead
them to the fighting tournament we just
want to see them bite kind of like
godzilla versus kong there are the fans
who love the mythology of it and there
are the fans that just
want to see them beat the piss out of
each other and it's not just piss it's
blood it's weird goo it's
uh everything i wanna know from you guys
what you thought of this trailer did you
love it what was your favorite part we
actually created a whole new channel for
this over on our official discord server
that you can access by being a patron at
patreon.com new rockstars the
conversation is going down there
another way you can support this channel
is by checking out one of our many great
merch options at new rockstarsmirch.com
you can get this shirt and pretty much
every other shirt you see me wearing the
new york stores videos follow me at
eavos follow new rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars hit that notification bell
for
reactions and breakdowns do all the
stuff you love thanks for watching see
you next time
get over here get over you get over here
and subscribe get
get over here get over here
[Music]
you